Something else that was
observed about moving lights.
So I'm showing you this picture, and
you probably don't see very much.
So you probably don't know what this is.
To me it's obviously a horse
jumping over a fence.
Except when I put it in motion, oh.
It's Meghan strolling along.
She has such a nice stroll.
No it's not, it's just some set of
random dots from some other exhibit.
Notice that that center point is fixed.
It's not moving at all.
And, in fact, if I erase that and
look at that,
and you just stare at that point,
the whole thing looks kind of weird.
But then if you just stop
looking at that point and
just look at the whole thing,
you see somebody moving.
Except now I can't get that weird
center point out of my head, all right?
But the idea is with this
very impoverished stimulus,
you are able to perceive
not just motion.
Remember, nothing is moving here, right?
There are no points
moving on the screen.
Point, point, point.
You see them moving.
Not only do you see points moving,
you see a person moving.
All there are are static
pictures of points.
That's all that's there.
The rest of what's going on is
being manufactured in your head.
And our goal, because we're
computational vision people,
is to think a little bit about how to
get the computer to manufacture some of
that information.